only eg got an epic tour of former
reality queen heather dubrow insane OC
spread can't wait a bit
oh hi Heather Dubrow lauren zima
what Heather Dubrow house you get a
glass of champagne upon entrance yes you
do come on any tea I'll get some champs
for you to the 21 million dollar home in
pricey Newport Beach is massive 22,000
square feet with seven bedrooms and
fourteen bathrooms the entryway sports a
30-foot ceiling that's actually a
semi-precious stone that I had backlit
up there and a little fun fact is that
it came in on the largest container ever
to come into the United States I mean
every gorgeous mansion in Orange County
needs a theater and a gym we check those
out let's do it
that home gym is totally tricked out
right down to monogrammed towels and
water bottles and of course working out
in high heels is oh so chic if it's good
enough for Mariah this is how would they
do it in Orange County in the dining
room nearly 300 bottles of children
click Oh champagne are mounted in this
wall art installation that's about
twelve thousand bucks of bubbly do you
literally know anyone else with a
champagne wall I know people that have
it now we're seeing it in my house that
so how'd they afford all this well
Heather's plastic surgeon hubby Terry
has started on five seasons of his own
reality series botched and Heather's an
actress who is the lead on the CBS
series that's life together they will be
live all weekend long on shop HQ with
their console beauty line of products
she hosts her own podcast Heather Dubrow
swirls and one watch a movie the
dubrow's state-of-the-art theater has 21
seats and comes with a 1 million dollar
price tag we were gonna give you a rough
estimate how many checks did you write
in the construction of this up I would
have to ask my wife how much right
there's white masters you know Heather
said they spent six hundred thirty
thousand dollars on the cabinets alone
crazy
[Music]